everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina we're here to bring you
this week's review of arrow season 2
episode 8 the scientist now there was a
rumor that there was some type of
character was gonna make an appearance
today yeah somebody with this new
character I've never heard who's Barry
Allen I never heard the name yeah so
scientists is showing up this kid who
lies about his identity we get a little
bit of his origin story what did you
think about Barry Allen making return
her debut on arrow
I loved it it was exciting you know it's
funny I feel like every single review
that we do and stuff I'm always ranting
and raving
she was so great the show so great but
it's like every single freaking episode
at least for me I've been pretty epic
really good like I've really been
enjoying it like Barry Allen like I was
excited I'm sure a lot of you guys out
there just excited to see Barry Allen as
I was and stuff and I thought it was
good I thought it was fun I liked the
fact that he looked like this young kid
you know
barely 20 right and stuff and a little
nerdy and stuff and created a little bit
of a drama Oh crying oh well something
about olicity olicity love triangle
felicity Melissa yes let's go jump to
the island is this showing us so
intently every week this jump jump jump
yeah no the love triangle on the island
may be perfect face face going just like
the mask taking the serum so guys I love
trend on the island now again the only
thing I love this series but I wish we
got a little more time on the island for
the beach so fast they do and there's so
much stuff happening on the island I
would love love to get at least one
episode just one episode there's just
all okis is on the island right because
there's so much story to tell on yeah
you know what I mean
I mean that just goes to show you how
good the show is that differently
different great stories going on yeah
it's not a bad thing there's one one
more exact more more so I guess I just
get to the big reveals I mean we'll get
system the small look at the big reveal
so another thing Malcolm Merlyn big
reveal laughter yeah and now she's like
Maura has some connection she mentions a
certain ratio Ghul ratio Ghul she or
Ra's al Ghul's are called in this season
depends on I guess what you want to call
it but I mean he
she knows him yeah Jimmy hello myself
well I'm not going to cell phone' but
she yeah yeah yeah smoke signals yes but
that was kind of like again one of those
singers like every single episode I'm
like wow you know that type of like
reaction and stuff because every episode
delivers a surprise
there's some things you won't expect
them even though like he kind of figured
we'd see or he least hear from rage you
know with the mention of the League of
Assassins and stuff so it was bound to
happen but it still is shocking that
that Moria Mora is even connected more
than I thought
Merlyn would know him better but he's
like how do you know that name and he's
just like oh I'm so you know he was so
happy to hear that you were alive he can
kill you wants the kid is a run
Mars getting tough she is like I like
that the direction or characters going
in stuff right you know cuz like all
like a season one is stuff she was kind
of a pushover Merlyn basically had you
know her wrapped around his finger and
so this is a different side that I like
to see and also you know it's a little
party at the house didn't go so well you
know some issues but she is tough she's
back to confident so I guess jumping
around again though would you think of
Barry Allen overall he was fun he was
funny I will see him in his own series
yeah exactly exactly you get a little
bit of his backstory it's not a full
origin obviously he's not flashed in
this episode you know what I mean but he
talks a little bit about like the fact
that he's looking for the killer his
mother's killer yeah you know and so I
thought he's funny I liked his
relationship the chemistry had with
Felicity was pretty funny again you know
trying to create a little bit like a
love triangle or something like that
which is nice you know but it was funny
was definitely fun character awkward
hurting self which I liked you know we
also got a little bit of brother blood
yeah a little bit kind of working with
the serum the whole you know drug that
makes them super strong and everything
thing that we were talking about this is
during the episode I kind of missed her
in you know speaking more DC stuff the
Dark Knight Rises I didn't I mean Bane
was a tough guy who knew martial arts
but he didn't actually have the serum
but never talked about venom or anything
like that I was we're actually seeing
we're getting Christopher Nolan's what
he's never I've never geeked out as much
as this dude well this isn't were for
like more comic book absolutely that was
just that was his thing his version of a
dark night of background stuff in the
world so you're absolutely right and
that's one of the things I love about
arrow because we're basically getting
what we did not dare those films and
what like a lot of fans have just
let's see the flash let's see who's the
the thing you saw today a little Oh Ted
Kord on yeah I was like a little bit of
piece of equipment there just poured on
it
Ted Kord is a Blue Beetle Blue Beetle so
I mean it's just a little like geeked
out a little more Easter eggs in this oh
that's got to be so real world exactly
and again they make a little reference
to the particle accelerator right have
you been point that out you know each
week we don't see the particle
accelerator and I like that we got
Barry's assessment of that he was like
oh that technology people say it's bad
but it's really not so I mean you know I
I know what they said they're gonna give
him his own origin story so I don't
think we're not gonna see him turn into
the flash there but those like we're
gonna get them next week a little taste
yeah exactly and this brings up the
question like we gotta talk about this
got a look ahead to the future possibly
we might now see ratio goal like before
I thought okay maybe he just be a name
examples drop because we know they cast
his illegitimate daughter another woman
not Talia is Holly's half-sister yeah
it's gonna be coming in Katrina law from
Spartacus so now we actually might see
maybe not this season yeah exactly
maybe next somewhere down the line cuz
now with her coming on board and
everybody's speculating that Isabel is
in fact ollie enough and now it's just
like it almost guarantees that you're
gonna have to see her as well right you
know at some point again like you said
maybe not this season maybe next right
another revelation and this is comic
book world so this could come this could
change he said I bow is dead yeah all
those had the drug but of course I don't
know about I will be in debt we thought
Malcolm Merlyn might have been dead
again a man no one's really no one's
really it's so easy to bring him back
and stuff right sunny the good thing is
we are gonna get more flash next be more
baryon pre flash Barry Allen he is
sticking around for at least another
episode I think after that maybe you
have one more if not this might be the
last one and then they're gonna take
which I always hate we all hate the big
winter break you know gonna be off
repellents but that's okay but I think
this so you're still liking it for the
first almost to the end of the first
half of the season I'm loving it every
sing like I said every single episode
just kind of blows me away it's it's
like one thing after another and I know
I've always mentioned before it's just
like oh you know can they keep this up
can they give us up it's like we're
pretty much halfway through this is
another rest about every single episode
just keeps delivering one of the I
really loved about this particular
episode the fight sequences where she
shot really well there was a cool set
piece when he was fighting the guy in
the truck and he stabbed him and then he
knocked him out but he like kind of like
skidded on
the door that you know there was good it
was absolutely yeah that let's do a
great great fight choreography on a very
small budget they always shoot basically
the same factory see what they have been
warehouse is always a warehouse but you
know CW they got to work with the messes
on HBO so I mean another great episode
of arrow looking forward to continuing
off next week more flash you know come
chat with us so talk to Mike and I share
your thoughts with us well it's no way
you geeked out the most about this week
with all the just so many revelations
this week so many things going on you
can find us at think here comm will
survey YouTube pages each page right
here just think hero Pro one check with
Michael Dennis any of the crew here at
think hero on Twitter we're at think
hero I'm at Griffin de and I'm at mr.
Michael Alexis we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
your fans
be sure to spread the word give us a
like like this video subscribe you know
as always always gonna hear your
feedback whether you hate this episode
if you liked it or you don't like our
opinions on it share it with us so you
know as always feel free to do that as
well
you